so we left off on the part where I asked
about why certain novels and their
fictionalized characters are not able to
become movies yeah well we were talking
about a literary function a literary
book it's all about the interior mind of
someone that's very difficult to turn
into a visual story but commercial
fiction like gone girl I mean that's
always gonna make great movies but again
it has to fit the genre we teach a lot
of novelists and we we tell them frankly
look we're gonna fit you into this
commercial structure of what we call the
BMOC
which is the character is gonna be asked
to change in these crescendos at this
point at this point at this point at
this point now if you don't want to do
that that's cool
but what you're gonna get from that is a
character who changes and a character
who changes visibly and this is amazing
we've had novelists who are literary
novelists come in and they don't really
want to be there their agents have asked
them to come to change to change their
story but when they understand the
rhythm of a commercial movie they go you
know what this actually improved my my
protagonist I I was forced to try to
understand what it is that I loved about
him and the other thing is I'm working
with a young adult writer who's very
very successful and who has her books
are taught in schools and um and she's
very very successful as a yef
but when she she's trying to write a
script and when I asked her okay what's
your character's core wound who's
teaching them who's healing them who's
not she was like you know what I don't
know I you're right I mean there's a
bunch of people in the book but none of
them really do that and I don't know the
answers that question and I'd like to
know the answers so generally speaking
novelists who
work with that's the reaction they have
and and if they don't have that reaction
I guess they don't tell us they just
slink away or they think oh ho ho stop
poor awful Hollywood people but our
tools are designed to make you ask the
questions
why does a character change or why does
he not change and and what does he have
to learn and who's asking him to change
so it's basic stuff but it's not the
approach of a lot of novelists to ask
these kinds of questions as I'm writing
a tone poem or writing I'm writing a
narrative of a life yeah so so literary
fiction we work with it all the time but
we are going to ask them these questions
you